او عائد مجدي يعني انت عايز فلوس علشان
تكمل في الحاجه اللي انت بتحبها مدى
الحياه
وده اللي انا بدات اعمله وشغل بدا يكبر
بدات تدبر السوشيال ميديا بتاعتي والحمد
لله يعني بدات اعمل منه فلوس حلوه والكلام
ده كان الحمد لله كانت باينه عندي بدري
فساعتها برضو ماما اللي كانوا خايفين علي
بقى احنا كنا في الاول قال لنا عليه بس
انت يعني اسباب في نفسك وعارفين هو ده
الطريق الصح كامله فانت عموما لما بتكمل
في الحاجه اللي انت بتحبها
هتلاقي نفسك ان انت هتعرف تكون اكتر بس مش
دايما هيكون عندك يعني وعايزين برده نفرق
ما بين
ممكن انت صح النهارده
يعني ما لوش نفس ان هو يروح فده الفرق ما
بين السفر
انك بتعمل الحاجه دي حتى لو انت مش عايز
تعملها عشان هي الحاجه دي اللي الهدف اللي
انت عايزه توصل له عمومي
وتعملها وكانك كمان بتحبها يعني ما حدش
فيها بيحدد فينا بيحب حاجات كثير بس انت
بتعمل الكلام ده لان ما بين نفسك عارف
اللي هو الكلام ده هيوصلك الحاجه اللي انت
محتاجها وتصلحها عموما في حياتك
فزي ما اتفقنا محتاج تطورها فيه
ازاي بتتكلم ودي كانت مميزات ان انا بدات
اشتغل بدري من وانا جامعه كنت يعني
اتعلمت ازاي اتعامل مع طلبات المجتمع
المختلفه عماله تعلم
في نفسك عشان تبيع سيرفس اللي انت عموما
ايا كان عايز تعملها كل حاجه في الدنيا لو
انت دكتور فانت بتبيع اللي انت هتعمله
فانت دي لسه داخل تتعلمها عموما هتتعلمها
اكتر بالممارسه
فحلوه انك تنزل تشتغل اي شغلانه عموما حتى
مع ايام الجامعه
واحسن استثمار عموما ممكن تعملوا ان انت
تستثمر في نفسك يعني فكره ان انتم يعني
الناس الجميله اللي قدام النهارده
هتطور في المايك حتى لو
فمعنى كده ان انت صح ممكن تكون حضرت حاجات
كتير زي دي قبل كده ولا كلمه بس على الاقل
انت ممكن هي دي المره اللي معاك بتاعته في
اوعى تستسلم على نفسك لازم تفضل تحاول مره
واثنين وثلاثه زي ما اتفقنا في اربع خطوات
كده هيحصلولك لو انت عايز تبدا تقوم اي
بيزنس واحنا زي ما احنا اتفقنا ان احنا
محتاجين
فاحنا محتاجين نجيب اتنشن لازم الناس كلها
بعرف ان انت موجود على كوكب الارض زي ما
اتفقنا لان مهما كانت اللي انت بتبيعها
الكلام ده حرفيا ما لوش اي تلاته لازمه لو
محدش يعرف ان انت موجود فاول حاجه اكيد
هتنسل بعد ما تنسى ما يكون
كلها جربنا قبل كده لو اي حد عموما عنده
انستجرام
شويه
يعني ده جزء من رحله كده كده هيتقف عليك
وهتلاقي صحابك اول ناس بيصفوا عليه فلازم
تعرف ان هو بعد
والتنمر ده لما يزيد واحده واحده هتلاقي
ان هو هيكون فيه ايه هتبدا بقى الناس بقى
تعمل سر الكلام دوت ومش
عارف واخر مرحله هيكون في حاجه اسمها
اللي هو الناس فعلا ممكن تخش على اكونت
كريم هتلاقي ان هو فعلا للناس بيساعد
الناس ان هي توصل لاحسن من نفسها
عموما فيبدا يكون فيها في الحقيقه اللي
انت عموما بتعملها
فانت عموما في رحلتك دائما في الحلم وفي
الوحش مش هينفع انت تاخد الحلو بس وتسيب
الوحش هي بقتش بتتاخد كامله بتشتغل
مع نفسك فانت لازم تعرف ان انت مثلا موظف
تبع ثمان ساعات لما البنت ازاي يكون بتاعك
هتشتغل اربعه مش كل الناس تعرف
تعمل ودائما انا بقول
بيخرجك بره الكونكر بتاعك اللي انت تكبر
في اي حاجه عموما في حياتك لما انت تخرج
من منطقه الكونفرسون لكن هي لو كل حاجه
ماشيه
في اي حاجه عموما بعكس الواحد صعبه وفضل
بيحاول وفيه واكشن داونز ده هيكون اجمل في
الحياه مليون مره عن الشخص اللي هو ايه
ان هو يطور لنفسه فلازم تعرف ان هو
الاستريسس لازم تتعامل معاه بطريقه حلوه
لو انت عموما شغال لوحدك حاجه حلوه لو انت
عايز تكبر شركه فلازم تعرف ان هو سايب
الربح هيزيد والفلوس هتزيد وكل حاجه هتكبر
لازم تعرف برده ان هو الاستريس ده هيزيد
لازم تعرف
وزي ما احنا اتفقنا هي الفكره كلها في
الجيرمي مش في الديسك
حلاوه الموضوع كله في الرحله في الاقصى
دوت في الحاجات اللي انت بتعلم منها في
المشاكل اللي بتحصل لك هتعرف ازاي تتعامل
معه
وقت بتاعي اللذيذ النهارده عشان انا مش
عايز اطول عليكم واحنا عارف ان هو يعني
بيكون 18 دقيقه وبعد كده المايك اهو
خلي الهدف بتاعك عموما كلنا في الحياه من
تدور على الفولفيلمنت اللي انت تحاول
توصل لاحسن حاجه انت ممكن تعملها ناس كتير
بتقول لي يا كريم انت بتشتغل كتير وهتبر
انا يعني قابلنا اوت اللي هو الفيروس
وهتتعب ومش هتقدر تكمل انا قابلني عموما
لو انا مش بعمل الحاجات اللي هو الهدف
بتاعي انا هبرت لو انا عارف ان انا كان
ممكن اوصل بكده احسن بكتير وانا مش باعمل
الكلام ده ساعتها انا فعلا حرفيا
فعايزين النهارده الهدف بتاعنا اللي انت
تحاول
انت ما بينك وبين نفسك لو قاعد وعارف ان
انت عندك اكتر بكتير انك ممكن تعمله وانا
متاكد ان هو الكلام ده موجود عند كل الناس
اللي قاعدين معنى كده
ان انت تعمل الكلام ده عشان هو الكلام ده
هيوصلك لشخص اللي انت عايز تنشر له في يوم
من الايام لكن احنا حاليا مش جاهزين فهي
الفكره كلها في الجيرمي يغسل شكرا شكرا
طولت عليكم
اسئله لو حد عنده سؤال
انا حاسس نفسي دكتور
[موسيقى]
اي حاجه اللي انت عايزه تقول لي كريم على
طول عادي
[موسيقى]
يعني اللي هو
اجرب اعمل حاجه جديده احسن ماده يعني انا
كده كده
موضوع الحمد لله دخلت الجامعه والحمد لله
كذا حاجه مع بعض بس مع الوقت اللي انت
هتلاقي ده
ده احلى وقت تاخد فيه الرزق
بابا وماما اكل موجود كل حاجه
موجود فانت لماسك دلوقتي انت
مش عموما بيكون اصعب مش بيكون اسهل
فالفكره كلها برضو هدف كبير جدا جدا جدا
بطريقه مرعبه لدرجه
ايه بس المهم ان هو الهدف يكون كبير لان
هو الجن بتاعتك ما فيش ضعف وهيكون فيه
ابسط هيكون فيه مشاكل كتير وهيكون في
حالات بتحصل كل يوم عشان انت تستخدم فلو
الهدف بتاعك كبير كفايه
هتلاقي نفسك مكمل فمهم ان انت يكون عندك
الحاجه اللي انت عايز
وما تخافش مش تعرف ان هو جزء من النجاح
وده اللي انا كنت بقوله الموضوع شجاعه
علشان تنجح في اي حاجه عموما في حيات
ك
فمهم ان هو الهدف بتاعك يكون كبير كفايه
لان هو ده اللي هيكون حاسس فيك كل شويه
بس كده
[تصفيق]
راجل بقوله دائما على السوشيال ميديا اسمه
بران
[موسيقى]
شخص ناجح
تبدا يبدا يغير بتاعتك يعني هو الفكره
كلها ما بين الشخص الناجح واللي مش ناجح
قوي
بتاعته وطريقه تفكيره ولازم تعرف اللي هو
الناس كلها
دي هو اللي
صحابه يعني انت لو عايز تاخذ ناجح في كل
حاجه عموما وعايز اللي هو ده اللي انا
عايز اكون زي الفل
فمهم جدا ان هو يكون عندك
مانجا ويغير لك من بتاعتك لان هو
اهم حاجه النجاح ده طريقه
حياتك كلها من ناحيه كل حاجه
لما انا بدات اللي هو طبعا كلنا كنا
عايزين نعمل فلوس والكلام ده هو بدا يغير
بتاعته انت بتبدا تحطه رقم معين انت عايز
تعمله فهو كان بيسال مثلا هل الرقم ان هو
يحصل طيب هل في ناس كتير بتعمله اه في ناس
كتير بتعمله طب هل ده هو في عموما لما
يكون لك هيبدا يغير في بتاعتك ودي اهم ودي
الحاجه الوحيده اللي فعلا كويسه كل الناس
اللي حواليك فحلم
واحد انا عايز يوم من الايام ونبدا نموت
الشخص ده معلم منه يعني لو
احنا كده اطمنا عليك يعني
في اي اسئله يا شباب
اللي هو السؤال موجود
انا جاي لك اهو
دلوقتي دكتور اسنان يعني لو الموضوع ده
ترجع
قبل
الطريقه
اول حاجه لازم ما بين
خلي بالك
احنا العشره شخصيات عن بعض في واحد يقول
لك انا عايز الحياه هاديه
اقعد في جزيره
قعدت مع اهلي عايز اروح كل يوم الشغل
بتاعي ارجع
مراتي وفي واحد تاني هي اللي بتكون بتاعها
اعلى فانت مثلا
وحلو بس
مليونير
الطريق بتاعك الطريق ده لازم تعرف ان هو
فعلا دغداء
والطريق ده مش كل الناس بت
جمل خلي بالك الناس اللي هو يعني يعني
فانت لو عايز الحياه جميله والكلام ده مش
غلط خالص بالعكس ده من حقك وعشان كده احنا
دايما الملز بتاعتنا كلها مختلفه
بتاعتنا كلها مختلفه عن بعض انت عايز تعمل
حاجه انا عايز اعمل
كده ان انت مش معنى كده ان انا طمعت
والناس اللي تفرق برضو ما بين ان انت عندك
طموح ودائما بيقول لك
هو الموضوع
في منتهى الحياه ان انت عايز
انت
عايزو انت ببساطه عايز توصل لاحسن
ايه دلوقتي
في الحياه ان انت بتدور على الحاجه
انا يعني لما يكون عندك 70 80 سنه انا
فعلا مبسوط بكل خطوه وانا عملتها في حياتي
بالابص دوت
[موسيقى]
لكن لو انا قدام ساعتها وارجع اقول يا ريت
كنت عملت كذا طب ده انا جربت ده انا في
واحد صاحبي عمل الحاجه اللي انا
قلتها ونجح فيها وهي اصلا
موجوده في كل حاجه الشخص اللي هينفذ
هو اللي هينفع والموضوع كله هو وعشان كده
انا قلت لك لو تاخد بالك
عشان لو انت عايز تعمل فلوس يعني هو انا
اول لما بدات لسه بدات اشد نفسي في الشغل
بتاعي
بدات اعمل فلوس حلوه
ايه
وفي الفتره بتاعت
كل دخل في حاجه اسمها
اللي معاه فلوس عايز يحافظ عليها لان
الناس كلها وقفت وما بقاش فيه ايه جاي
فكله دخل في مرحله اسمها ايه
والكلام مع كل الناس اللي معايا في المجال
وانا كان معايا مبلغ محجوز في وصول بتاعي
انا
يعني
انا بتكلم فيه ده
انا صرفت كلها وقعدت
الفتره دي
فعشان كده
انت عايز تعملها الكرات بتاعك انا قلت لك
ان انت عايز توصل كلمه عايز تحس ان انت
راضي لما يقول عندك 70 80 سنه لما تيجي
بقى لما ترجعش تقول يا ريت
الدنيا كل واحد يسمع نفسه
فاتمنى تكون هي دي الاجابه او انا فهمت
سؤالك حاجه تانيه
بالعكس
يعني
المخاطره لو انا هعمل حاجه
فهو لازم
خلي بالك القلم
ين سنه بتخيل
هنا انا جايب لك
يبقى هو ده الطريق في الفيديوهات بتاعك
انا عايز اقول